ils sont dans les 50 meilleurs de france
les jeunes du pôle espoirs de l'équipe
de france de break était en stage aux
mureaux pendant une semaine
au programme entraînement physique
intensif et démonstrations devant un
public novice mais visiblement conquis
je connaissais pas mon fils de 5 ans
vers une fois qu'ils en appelaient j'ai
suivi des cours et
ça m'a plu ça me rappelle pas mal
maintenant je participe à des shows
comme comme si on n'avait pas ça avant
je parle de 2018 2019 le moment où ça
s'est concrétisé avec les jeux
olympiques c'est vachement cool tout ça
qu'on puisse avancer à disposition
vraiment effectif et c'est cool dépassé
ses capacités copé veut savoir
l'internaute soit espoirs dépassé de
physique au travail sur les mains on
travaille sur la dette des choses qui
sont pas forcément faciles l'occasion
aussi d'attirer de nouveaux adeptes lors
d'une initiation
aux défis qui nettoie tout fêté à manier
ce qui m'a plu sic et bat ou s'entraîner
douce et puis on regarde et on pouvait
refaire les mêmes figures une discipline
qui se démocratise de plus en plus avec
son entrée aux jeux olympiques 2000 24 à
paris avec les jeux olympiques vraiment
ça donne une ampleur qu'on n'aurait
jamais pensé c'est pas du sapin
s'appelle giteau a été créé pour ça la
bosse donc vraiment c'est cool de voir
une évolution qui postent de quelque
chose qui a été fait dans les rues extra
sur des cartons l arrivée aux jeux
olympiques donc pouvoir être médailles
aux jo page you le break est une culture
qui est quand même assez suivi on le
voit même dans des événements pas
forcément fédéraux que ça attire le
public parce que c'est
intergénérationnel les parents viennent
avec leurs enfants ils passent un bon
moment c'est un vrai enjeu pour notre
territoire de représenter le breaking
dawn être référent début française pour
l'organisation et la mise en place
d'actions autour du bric est un
événement qui prouve la volonté de faire
des mureaux une terre de breakdance
prochain rendez vous le championnat
inter régionaux de breaking le 2 avril
prochain et il est champion prend un
vrai piège